benoît hamon parle de trahison quand
jean yves le drian rejoint monaco vous
employer les mêmes termes alors d'abord
je voudrais saluer le courage de benoît
hamon
parce que l'opération qui est fait
contre lui avec des annonces successives
vous savez les petites gouttes dit jours
après je le trouve les obliger oui oui
je pense que c'est volontaire alors ça
vous savez quand il s'est organisé quand
il ya un qui s'exprime dans le jdd le
dimanche une autre le lundi et bertrand
delanoë qui fait la matinale de mardi je
pense que enfin je vous savez j'ai vu
que ça cette opération là bas les gares
d'europe écologie les verts donc je sais
bien qu'ils d'ailleurs du seul homme je
pense que les gens qui sont autour de la
candidature d'emmanuel maquereau ou
peut-être d'ailleurs ceux qui ne veulent
pas que benoît hamon réussisse moi je ne
crois qu'il ya vraiment une partie des
socialistes qui n'ont pas supporté
manuel larimer que la primaire donne
raison à l'analyse de certains dont je
fais partie qui était un désaveu du
tournant qu'a pris lé quinquennat
notamment en 2014 et que voilà il ya eu
un vote ya eu une décision et ils l'ont
toujours pas supporté oui mais manuel
valls il a écrit une tribune pour le
dire alors qu'il a signé un papier on
voit son écriture manuscrite autorité
des primaires a contesté oui bien sûr il
ya la volonté de déstabiliser benoît
hamon moi c'est pour ça que je veux
saluer à la fois son courage sa ténacité
et puis son son originalité parce que
vous avez rappelé le débat mais au moins
il dit des choses il fait des
propositions
on sait où sera la france dans cinq ans
si benoît hamon est présent la
république et moi je serais beaucoup
plus rassuré que de dire qu'une
opération marketing a marché même si
nous vous avez raison ça fonctionne